LAWLESSNESS.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF THE FIRST
PART OF TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
WE'VE GOT LOTS OF BIG
IMMIGRATION STORIES TO GET TO
TONIGHT.
FIRST UP, CALIFORNIA
GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM CONTINUES
HIS WAR AGAINST LOW INCOME AND
MIDDLE INCOME AMERICANS BY
BUILDING A MORE POWERFUL MAGNET
TO DRAW ILLEGAL ALIENS TO HIS
STATE.
THIS TIME?
BY GIVING THEM STATE MEDICAID
BENEFITS.
>> WE ARE THE MOST UN-TRUMP
STATES WHEN IT COMES TO HEALTH
POLICY AND I'M PROUD OF THAT.
NOT JUST AS GOVERNOR OF
CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE PROVIDING HEALTH CARE TO
EVERYONE REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS.
IF YOU BELIEVE IN UNIVERSAL
HEALTH CARE, YOU BELIEVE IN
UNIVERSAL HEALTH CARE.
WE WANT TO BE HERE TO CELEBRATE
WHAT'S RIGHT IN THIS COUNTRY AND
CONTRAST OUR APPROACH WITH THE
APPROACH COMING OUT OF
WASHINGTON, D.C.
>> Laura: THAT GRAVELLY VOICE
OF HIS DOES NOT MAKE HIM ANY
MORE PERSUASIVE.
WHAT'S RIGHT, HE SAID?
IS HE KIDDING US?
ALL RIGHT.
GAVIN, YOU HAVE RUNAWAY
HOMELESSNESS IN YOUR STATE, A
TOTAL CRISIS RIGHT NOW.
MOST NOTABLY IN SAN FRANCISCO
AND L.A.
IT'S CREATING FILTHY AND
INFECTIOUS CONDITIONS FOR
CALIFORNIANS AND ESPECIALLY
THOSE LOW INCOME CITIZENS WHO
DON'T SEND THEIR KIDS TO FANCY
PRIVATE SCHOOLS.
>> FOR SOME REASON, THE STATE
AND IN PARTICULAR THE LOCAL
OFFICIALS OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND LOS ANGELES, THE
CITY COUNCIL, THE MAYOR,
REVIEWED TO ACKNOWLEDGE WHAT
THIS IS.
IN MEANTIME, THEY PERPETRATE A
HOAX AND I CANNOT EXPLAIN WHY.
>> Laura: THE GOVERNMENT LED
BY NEWSOM IS SO PATHETIC AT
ADDRESSING THIS CRISIS THAT
BUSINESSES IN L.A. ARE NOW
PLANTING THORNY PLANS AND OTHER
STUFF AROUND THEIR BUILDINGS TO
TRY TO KEEP THE HOMELESS AWAY.
WHY CALIFORNIANS KEEP VOTING IN
THESE DESTRUCTIVE AND DELINQUENT
POLITICIANS IS COMPLETELY BEYOND
ME.
MY FRIENDS, IT'S ALL A
DEMOCRAT-INDUCED DISASTER.
INSTEAD OF FOCUSING ON THINGS
LIKE, I DON'T KNOW, MENTAL
HEALTH, INFECTIOUS DISEASE
PROBLEMS THAT ARE PLAGUING THIS
STATE, THE POLITICIANS OF
CALIFORNIA ARE SPENDING
$98 MILLION MORE TO EXPAND
EXTEND
HEALTH CARE TO ILLEGALS.
THAT'S ON TOP OF THE BILLIONS
THEY ALREADY SPEND ON THEM.
THE WHOLE COUNTRY WILL SOON
BECOME THE NEXT CALIFORNIA IF
THE DEMOCRATS GET THEIR WAY.
>> WE DO OURSELVES NO FAVORS BY
HAVING 11 MILLION UNDOCUMENTED
PEOPLE IN OUR COUNTRY BE UNABLE
TO ACCESS HEALTH CARE.
>> REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THEY
ARE DOCUMENTED OR UNDOCUMENTED,
WE HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO PROVIDE
CARE.
>> RAISE YOUR HAND IF YOUR
GOVERNMENT PLAN WOULD PROVIDE
COVERAGE FOR UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS.
>> Laura: ALL RIGHT.
AS WE CONSIDER THE NATIONAL
IMPLICATIONS OF THIS OPEN
BORDERS MANIA, WE SHOULD NOT
FORGET THAT SANCTUARY POLICIES
LIKE CALIFORNIA'S HAVE LED TO
TRAGIC RESULTS.
ATTRACTING AND PROTECTING THE
MOST DANGEROUS ELEMENTS OF THE
ILLEGAL POPULATION.
POLICE OFFICERS MURDERED.
IN COLD BLOOD.
BY IN THE ILLEGAL ALIEN DEPORTED
FIVE TIMES WHO KEPT REPORTING
BACK TO THE STATES.
>> [BLEEP].
[BLEEP]!
LEAVE.
HIS [BLEEP] I WILL KILL MORE.
>> Laura: OTHERS HAVE BEEN
GUNNED DOWN IN THE PRIME OF
THEIR LIVES.
THE HORRIFIC RAPE OF A YOUNG
TEEN BY AN EVERGREEN ARRESTED
TWICE FOR ILLEGALLY ENTERING THE
COUNTRY.
BUT THE DEMOCRATIC LEADERSHIP
DOESN'T LIKE TALKING ABOUT THOSE
VICTIMS.
INSTEAD, THEY FOCUS ON VILIFYING
OUR BORDER PATROL AND I.C.E.
THESE CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATS AND
THOSE SEEKING NATIONAL OFFICE
NEED TO RECOGNIZE THAT THEY WERE
ELECTED TO REPRESENT THE